i want to start today with a correction
if i get something wrong or if i'm not
clear or if i'm incomplete about
something i always try to do these at
the top of the show i have no intention
of hiding the corrections on the back
page so to speak as is often the case
with newspapers or other publications so
let me get right into that yesterday i
did this segment about fox news
propagandist tucker carlson siding with
vladimir putin and sort of writing off
ukraine saying ukraine isn't even a
democracy
and sort of softly justifying or
defending or excusing vladimir putin's
invasion of ukraine and i made a lot of
critiques of ukraine in that segment
that are true
including that there are concerns in
ukraine about women's rights
there is corruption in ukraine there's a
lack of true rule of law in ukraine
number of other concerning elements in
ukraine but i didn't make clear
that tucker is wrong about ukraine not
being a democracy ukraine is a democracy
more or less and certainly way more than
russia is if you look at the freedom
index
freedomhouse.org you'll see that
ukraine is a 60 out of 100 on the
freedom index which is sort of a measure
of democracy
uh russia is a 20. so 60 puts ukraine as
partly free
20 puts russia as not free
so if i didn't make clear or i misstated
ukraine is a democracy albeit a flawed
one and ukraine is moving in the
direction of being more democratic
whereas recently russia has moved in the
direction of being less democratic um
the ukrainian president zelensky
genuinely won an election a real
election he's in over his head for sure
there were some problems with the
election but it was he won he he won uh
he did not control the election in the
way that vladimir putin controls
elections in russia
um and so this is a correction i didn't
make that clear yesterday zielinski is
not an authoritarian autocrat vladimir
putin is and that is a crucial
difference between russia and ukraine it
doesn't resolve any other issue it
doesn't excuse the things that are not
okay in ukraine
but i appreciate the opportunity to make
that correction
yesterday president joe biden spoke to
the nation again about the situation in
russia and ukraine with vladimir putin
invading ukraine on the premise that hey
we've got to keep the peace
in these independent regions that i've
recognized as independent even though
they're in another country and we
already talked yesterday about why that
entire framing doesn't make any sense it
violates a number of different
international protocols
but the latest is well what is joe biden
going to do
and joe biden is in a politically
difficult situation because no matter
what he does the right is going to
criticize him the right is criticizing
joe biden so let's go back
first the right attacked biden when it
came to russia
saying we should want to be friends with
russia we should we don't want conflict
with russia we don't want war with
russia fine okay uh but insisting that
biden would be too harsh on russia
whereas trump was more friendly and open
yeah we know uh then very quickly the
right shifted to saying trump would have
been would have been harsher with russia
so putin never would have tried this if
trump was still president biden is being
too weak with russia
but then at the same time they're sort
of defending what vladimir putin is
doing saying yeah you know
putin seems to be going to places where
they want him in ukraine we'll get to
that later and kind of defending what
vladimir putin is doing and at the same
time they're saying well the sanctions
that biden is putting on russia
are not nearly strict enough so they
want all sides of this i want to just
speak clearly to you
joe biden has put in place some
sanctions and we're going to talk about
those here is biden yesterday making it
clear
that this is an invasion by vladimir
putin take a look last few months we've
coordinated closely with our nato allies
and partners in europe and around the
world to prepare that response
we've settled along and i've told putin
to his face some mon a month more than a
month ago that we would act together
and the moment russia moved against
ukraine
russia has now undeniably moved against
ukraine by declaring these independent
states
so today i'm announcing the first
tranche of sanctions to impose cost on
russia in response to their actions
yesterday
these have been closely coordinated with
our allies and partners and will
continue to escalate sanctions if russia
escalates
we're implementing full blocking
sanctions
on two large russian financial
institutions
veb
and their military bank
we're implementing comprehensive
sanctions on russian sovereign debt
that means we've cut off russia's
government
from western financing it can no longer
raise money from the west and cannot
trade in its new debt on our markets or
european markets either
starting tomorrow and continuing in the
days ahead we'll also impose sanctions
on russia's elites and their family
members
they share in the corrupt gains of the
kremlin policies and should share in the
pain as well
because of russia's actions we've worked
with germany to ensure nordstrom 2
will not as i promised will not move
forward
as russia contemplates its next move we
have our next move prepared as well
russia will pay an even steeper price if
it continues its aggression including
additional sanctions okay and then joe
biden uh going on to say that
even what he has done so far is not the
full scope of what he is willing to do
take a look this is the beginning of a
russian
invasion of ukraine as he indicated and
asked permission to be able to do from
his duma
so let's begin to uh so i i'm going to
begin to impose sanctions in response
far beyond the steps we and our allies
and partners implemented in 2014.
and if russia goes further with this
invasion we stand prepared to go further
as with sanctions so the big discussion
the serious discussion you know all
these
right-wing gutter people that are just
going to criticize biden no matter what
he does i'm not really interested in
engaging with them let's let's engage
with a serious criticism which is
are these sanctions going far enough
and despite repeating that the u.s won't
send troops to ukraine
is the u.s basically fighting this as a
proxy war so let's take these two
questions one by one first of all
are the sanctions put in place by the
united states
that strict and the answer is
sort of but not really one of the real
concerns about the very first set of
sanctions was you're really just
sanctioning the regions that putin
invaded
you're not really hitting russians and
russia directly now with the sanctioning
of russian banks
and more
russian billionaires and their families
and their assets and ability to move
assets you are more directly hitting
russia proper but you could go a lot
further why isn't biden doing it well
you'd have to ask him why he's not doing
it
but it makes sense that you've got to
keep something off the you've got to
keep something on the table rather
in case putin goes further because there
is speculation at this point and so far
most of the speculation has been borne
out to be accurate in in terms of what
putin has done so far there's
speculation that putin's ambitions are
greater than the donets and luhansk
regions that so far he has sent troops
to
if putin wants to push further into
ukraine up to and including the
ukrainian capital kiev and wants to try
to affect regime change installing a
puppet government who knows what putin's
ambitions are you need to leave
something more on the table
geopolitically and from a foreign
relations standpoint it makes sense you
don't do everything yet
because you suspect putin has not done
everything yet so
we are getting to harsher sanctions
and and it is logical to not go fully
out because you've got to be able to
bring down more if and when vladimir
putin pushes further into ukraine now on
the proxy war question i think we just
have to accept at this time that the u.s
is waging a proxy war against russia now
sometimes by proxy war we mean
both parties are using proxies in this
case it is russia pushing into ukraine
and the us using
nato
sanctions
and arming of ukraine and supporting
ukraine as a proxy to fighting russia
directly and proxy wars are not
objectively good or bad but we have to
recognize that while joe biden has said
we're not going to put boots on the
ground um we're not drunk we're not
using drones and at least um
for the time being we're not doing cyber
attacks on russia
we are engaged in a sort of war here and
that is not an endorsement or a
criticism but it is a reality and that
is something that we're going to discuss
more on tomorrow's program
if you thought it was wild and
unprecedented when donald trump attacked
his own former vice president mike pence
for not trying to overturn an election
that he lost that is nothing
compared with what donald trump did
yesterday
clearly enamored with vladimir putin and
remember
trump has said he has fallen in love
with dictators before and then we fell
in love right that was about kim jong-un
trump enamored with vladimir putin
yesterday
called
genius putin's invasion of ukraine
using the pretext of recognizing the
independence of those two regions
smart
and savvy
guys trump is in love trump is in love
he loves putin
and he loves the invasion trump appeared
yesterday on the clay travis and buck
sexton show i don't know what that is
but trump
clearly doing lots of right wing shows
and here is what he had to say and he's
just smitten with vladimir putin we know
russia has said that they are
recognizing to two breakaway regions of
ukraine and now this white house is
stating that this is an invasion
that's a strong word what went wrong
here what has the current
occupant of the oval office done that he
could have done differently
well what went wrong was a rigged
election so first of all
there is no question that trump can
answer without mentioning the big lie
that he actually won okay so but let's
that's not what we're going to focus
today what went wrong is a candidate
that shouldn't be there and a man that
has no concept of what he's doing i went
in yesterday and there was a television
screen and i said this is genius
putin
declares a big portion
of the ukraine of ukraine putin declares
it as independent oh that's wonderful so
putin
is now saying it's independent a large
section of ukraine
i said how smart is that and he's going
to go in and be a peacekeeper
he is smitten now some of you have
pointed out
trump sort of seems to be using a tone
that suggests he recognizes
the cynical nature of what putin is
doing and i agree i agree tr trump sees
what putin is doing but he still is so
impressed i'm not saying he likes it but
he's so impressed with how putin has
done this that's the strongest peace
force we could use that on our southern
border that's the strongest peace force
i've ever seen there were more army
tanks than i've ever seen they're going
to keep peace all right no but think of
it here's a guy who's very savvy i know
i'm very very savvy very well very very
well by the way this never would have
happened with us had i been in office
not even thinkable this would never have
happened but here's a guy that says you
know
i'm going to declare
a big portion of ukraine independent he
used the word independent and we're
going to go out and we're going to go in
and we're going to help keep peace
you got to say that's pretty savvy so
trump of course
an undertone of
what putin is doing i would not have
allowed it to happen
but he is just in love with vladimir
putin can you imagine what fox news and
the other republicans would be doing if
biden or some other democratic leader
called what putin was doing genius smart
savvy trump is basically saying putin is
super smart and this is all genius and
it never would have happened if i was in
the white house but it is incredible
that this guy was so brilliant that he
was able to do this and by the way
uh with with a lot of these right
wingers
it is incredible how they are very soft
on the violation of ukraine's border
integrity by russia
while saying oh my god when it comes to
the u.s mexico border we've got to have
a border we've got to enforce it there
is nothing more sacrosanct than the u.s
mexico border but the ukraine russia
border it's sort of up to putin's
opinion where where that should be
incredible this guy just loves these
authoritarian dictatorial autocrats and
you can hear it in his voice you can
hear it in his voice there's a little
bit of sarcasm and there's a little bit
of like wow what what how audacious
but it is a guy who is genuinely
impressed with the things vladimir putin
is doing he's
it's it's not a surprise it's not a
surprise if you're hearing something
different in trump's voice there
let me know you can find me on twitter
at d pacman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show is an independent
viewer and listener supported program i
would love for you to sign up at
joinpackman.com we do a lot for our
members including producing a daily
additional show for you called the bonus
show alex jones hates the bonus show oh
the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad right he even
calls it predatory that is a freaking
predator right there right if there is
any better endorsement of the bonus show
it's that alex jones is so angry about
it and you can sign up at joinpakman.com
you'll also get the daily show
six hours before everybody else
with no commercials so there are many
perks to membership
at joinpakman.com
let's continue cataloging and evaluating
some of the different reactions from
right-wing figures to the invasion of
ukraine by russian president vladimir
putin over the last few hours and things
are changing so rapidly that it is hard
to say this is where things are right
now but at least over the last few hours
we have not learned of any further push
into ukraine so far vladimir putin has
recognized separatists in the donetsk
and luhansk regions as independent
and then sent troops in
to keep the peace
on the basis that these are now
independent separatists who want to be
part of russia donald trump on a
podcast interview we played last segment
thought that it was genius savvy and
smart donald trump also put out a
written statement about what is going on
in russia ukraine and as usual it is
riddled with the same contradictions and
confusions that we have seen
from donald trump for a long time i will
read it to you donald trump publishing
this yesterday quote if properly handled
there was absolutely no reason that the
current that the situation currently
happening in ukraine should have
happened at all i know vladimir putin
very well and he would have never done
during the trump administration what he
is doing now no way now
missing in that
that there's already a lot to analyze
there and i know that it's easy to just
see the things trump says and kind of
write them off as the rantings of a
lunatic and that that you would not be
wrong to do that but when he says putin
never would have done this during the
trump administration
what trump wants you to believe
is that putin was scared of trump and so
he never would have tried this during
the trump administration the problem
with that is twofold number one
trump and the rights whole attitude to
putin during the trump administration
was
we should be nice to putin not that we
should be tough with putin so trump's
idea that putin wouldn't have done this
during the trump administration because
trump's so tough goes directly counter
to the narrative they were giving us
which is trump is friendly and correct
to be friendly with vladimir putin
that's number one the second piece is
it's possible let's imagine that trump
is right
putin would never even have thought of
this during the trump administration
one possible reason why putin would not
have thought would not think of doing
this during the trump administration
would be that he feels as though he
doesn't need to
because the world attitude to putin is
much more friendly thanks to trump and
one
foreign policy analysis one section of
foreign policy analysis about why putin
is doing this now is well with trump
gone and biden here
the global community is more hostile to
russia when it comes to nato expansion
when it comes to whatever
nordstrom etc and so putin feels he
needs to do something so i'm not saying
any one of these analyses is the right
one but there are many reasons why trump
could be
in a literal sense correct that misstate
the reasons behind it okay let's
continue
back to the quote russia has become very
very rich during the biden
administration with oil prices doubling
and soon to be tripling and quadrupling
now trump is trying to
link
biden to gas prices going up and of
course gas prices uh oil prices rather
started going up during the trump
administration due to the resurgence and
demand uh as covid started to wane or at
least we thought it was starting to wane
and so that increase started under trump
and it simply continued under joe biden
presidents have very little that they
can do about gas prices and oil prices
there's a strategic petroleum reserve
we've talked about that but it is it is
not even fair to say that it is related
to biden uh but donald trump wants you
to think that it is
lastly the weak sanctions are
insignificant relative to taking over a
country and a massive piece of
strategically located land so here trump
is is acting tough
now it has begun oil prices are going
higher and higher putin is not only
getting what he always wanted but
getting because of the oil and gas surge
richer and richer the us was energy
independent under the trump
administration we actually still are we
did that story monday
and independence we never had before oil
prices would have remained low now what
a mess our country is in so just about
everything trump is saying there is uh
wrong uh lie or deceptive and
it should be interpreted as such but the
biggest sort of
most obvious
hypocrisy from the right at this point
in time is they were always talking
about we shouldn't be super tough with
the with russia democrats want us to
have a bad relationship they want to be
strict they want to sanction they want
to be tough and at the same time now
they're saying well
biden's not being tough enough and we
talked about the sanctions earlier
i do think early they were weak
they are getting tougher i also think
you need to leave something on the table
in case putin does push further into
ukraine we discussed that earlier but
trump's foreign policy analysis worth
basically what we paid for it
which is nothing
let's move on now to some other
right-wing figures who were just gushing
or defending or very impressed with
vladimir putin's invasion of ukraine
and it is absolutely fascinating to see
how the standards that the right demands
be applied to the u.s mexico border
the very same right ignores
in the context of putin ignoring the
sovereignty of ukrainian borders even
though there are numerous accords that
say actually russia has to respect the
ukrainian borders and you really have to
see this to believe it yesterday we look
looked at clips from the day before
in which
tucker carlson softly defended putin's
invasion by saying
ukraine's not even really a democracy
and ignoring the fact that when it came
to the u.s mexico border tucker sang a
very different tune well now we have
more examples candace owens now says
listen if we just listen to putin
uh we'd know
that uh this is actually
uh not really putin's wrongdoing candace
owens tweeting yesterday quote i suggest
every american who wants to know what's
actually going on in russia and ukraine
read this transcript of putin's address
as i've said for months nato under the
direction from under direction from the
united states is violating previous
agreements and expanding eastward we are
at fault now multiple things there okay
first of all candace owens is saying
just read the transcript she's basically
saying listen to but if you don't speak
russian you have to read a translated
transcript
just listen if you want to know the
truth listen to what putin said two
nights ago
anybody who saw that and had a
transcript with them that they read
along which i did
should immediately recognize
that it was a confused
disheveled all over the place putin
rambling
nonsensically and completely failing to
justify in any legal or moral way
his invasion of ukraine but candace
owens is saying just listen to what the
authoritarian said and take him at his
word and then you'll understand what's
going on that's number one number two
i've already told you they are falsely
repeating this idea
that nato is violating agreements by
expanding eastward i've already talked
to you guys about this and you can go
back and look at my clip from last week
about this it is not true it is not true
that nato had committed
to not expand eastward there was
initially a verbal discussion made
during negotiations decades ago about
nato not expanding eastward and not ever
considering adding ukraine
those were
never codified and they were removed
before anything was signed now we can
have a reasonable conversation about if
you're russia
do you consider the eastward expansion
of nato and the consideration of maybe
someday ukraine will be part of nato if
you're russia could you consider that a
form of aggression sure we can have
that's absolutely something we can do
but this idea that
nato is just in the wrong here there was
an agreement there was no such agreement
next let's go to charlie kirk
charlie kirk sort of also softly runs
interference for putin by saying i don't
know guys i mean maybe it's an invasion
maybe it's not but they seem to kind of
be welcoming putin there why does putin
feel so empowered the entire western
world is putting sanctions right now on
russia as they call this an invasion
farewell might be i'm not the
i'm not the person to determine whether
there's an invasion or an annexation it
feels as if putin is going into places
that want him they have voted
overwhelmingly to be part of it it's a
family dispute that we shouldn't get in
the midst of that's for certain but why
does putin feel
as if
now's the perfect time right well he
definitely waited for the olympics to be
over for all the cheaters on his team
that weren't even on the russian
federation team it was the russian
olympic committee
to be over with he didn't want the
spectacle in the midst of the olympics
he did annex crimea after the olympics
in um
2000 either 2006 or 2010 he has a
tendency to do this right after the
olympics or make uh big moves after that
i was trying to actually georgia was
after the olympics we'll get those dates
figured out
but why does putin feel so
let's say compelled at this particular
moment
to move
why even get close to this
so in a time when the entire planet is
locked down
due to the
chinese coronavirus finally the world is
reopening
there's
one number in particular that vladimir
putin is looking at that his entire
economy is organized behind and that is
the petro dollar okay so consider that
charlie kirk from turning point usa has
been ranting for years about mexico must
respect our borders they are our borders
they are internationally valid they must
be respected
but putin doesn't have to respect
ukraine's borders even though there are
actual agreements saying you have to
respect ukraine's borders come on guys
come on
and then lastly here's sort of a bonus
this is fox and friends fox and friends
actually um uh they admit putin is doing
a bad boy but they say it's joe biden's
fault putin is calling those troops
peacekeepers uh that's that's the first
guys of peacekeepers one man's invader
is another man's peacekeeper but these
two breakaway regions have been disputed
for eight years they're not really
breakaway they were taken along the same
time when crimea was taken all and
frankly the reason that it's so
precarious for ukraine is even belarus
on the on the northern part it's a
controlled uh it's controlled by russia
so on all look how big that thing is
yeah but they don't it's gigantic it's
the second biggest country in that part
of the world the bread basket and those
those don boss region has huge energy
resources manufacturing resources it's
been coveted by vladimir putin and if
you listen to what he said i mean he the
words he used in that speech were no
different than any other uh autocrat of
the soviet union true i mean so it's
like so far they're basically right here
that's what he wants to read he's got
one playbook and the first time he's
he's gone to it again the putin playbook
he's done this before when he when he
went into uh when everything happened
with georgia
the experts are wondering if he's going
to stop with these regions and they
worry he wants to go farther and farther
and then eventually take over the black
sea china and taiwan are watching he
knows how biden handled afghanistan that
was a disaster he also lost two
embassies he's lost the afghanistan
embassy and now the ukrainian embassy
has moved to poland when he was vice
president benghazi happened and even we
know that that's why this is happening
guys it's because benghazi happened when
biden was vp
and biden left afghanistan so now that's
why putin is doing this so no matter
what no matter what this is either
something that's fine
or
it's something that's not fine and it's
joe biden's fault that's the analysis
from right wing media we'll have these
clips on our instagram which you can
find at david pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpakmanshow so we knew
that at some point kyle rittenhouse
riding high on the heroism of his not
guilty verdict as per the right
uh after he killed uh a couple of people
um would somehow come back and be used
by the right in some way that maybe he
would understand and maybe he would not
understand but he was going to become a
tool of the right at least until
his celebrity sort of runs out it
already may be running out actually
because he has now started an
organization that no one seems to care
about and he barely seems to even
understand what it is about so we're
gonna look at a clip and you almost
start to feel bad for the kid because
he's just getting used he doesn't know
what's going on he doesn't know you know
down from up and day from night newsweek
reports kyle rittenhouse launches a fund
to finance lawsuits targeting media lies
even that is more coherent than how
rittenhouse explained it to tucker
carlson uh
on his program which we're gonna get to
in a moment
um
this is a new donation fund where you
can donate
and then they will
hold accountable
media outlets and individuals it's
called the media accountability project
and i guess what it will be used to do
is to finance lawsuits now i'm gonna
play for you
the
uh i'm gonna play for you a clip of kyle
rittenhouse being interviewed by tucker
carlson on on monday night
and rittenhouse seems to have no idea
what's going on i mean just absolutely
no clue what this even is at one point
he nervously drinks water and looks off
camera he seems confused and tucker
carlson is like trying to help him
almost explain what it is that he's
doing and so
we can come to only a couple of
conclusions one of which is
he has no idea what they're doing uh or
number two he's in way over his head all
right let's take a look forward kyle
thanks so much for coming on tonight i
can't think of many people who've been
at the receiving end of this much
sinister lying from so-called news
organizations right you have
how are you going to respond
well tucker thank you for having me um
of course me and my team have decided to
by the way he has a team now that's
that's even
i would love to know who who is on his
team that's advising him launched the
media accountability project as a tool
to help fundraise and hold the media
accountable for the lies they said and
deal with them in court
wow kyle that's really something
tell us more please
interesting so the idea is
maybe like the covington catholic kids
you will be and if you're watching you
just saw him
in a panicked way look off camera okay
suing news organizations that
maliciously lie about people who are in
the news right is that the plan
yes sir we're going to be holding them
accountable tucker
do you
he has no idea what he's doing and you
know we're laughing at it because it's
so it's impossible you know to avoid
laughing
but we really should almost like feel
bad that now he's clearly being taken
advantage of and it's not even clear
whether if you donate money to this
media accountability project tmap the
media accountability project it's not
even clear the money really will be used
for lawsuits i mean remember this is a
very common right-wing grift
which is trump did it after the 2020
election trump said hey
this we i need your help
i need you to donate i need you to
donate so that we can fund recounts
and legal challenges and flip some
states and if you looked at the fine
print
at least half the money was not even
potentially going to be used for that
and of course they didn't do the
recounts they didn't do any of it you
just you gave me trump money and trump
did what he wanted with the money and it
very well could be a similar thing here
but in terms of written house clearly
being taken advantage of he doesn't have
any idea what they're doing he doesn't
know how they're going to be doing it
he doesn't know
how any of this stuff works
and i am not
ignoring the irony
that fox here tucker is promoting tucker
by bringing on kyle
is promoting someone who who says i want
to hold the media accountable for lying
when it is fox news that for over a year
has welcomed liars about the 2020
election and covid and vaccines it is
fox news who arguably should be held
accountable and that irony
i mean it's not that it's lost on tucker
it's just completely missing even from
any notion of a consideration that he
might have and so uh this is the latest
scam
and kyle rittenhouse at the end of the
day is probably being used i don't think
he knows what's going on you know the
wright loves to say biden doesn't have
any idea what's going on he doesn't know
what he's doing he doesn't know what
he's actually signing
kyle rittenhouse has no clue what this
is about
and uh if you were actually subjected to
real questioning here it would get very
bad and at the end of the day he's
basically a kid i guess legally he's an
adult now i think now he's 18. but this
is basically a clueless kid
being uh
lionized because he got away with
killing a couple people
and
now is being used even further to try to
push the goals that he barely
understands of people who are using his
what i think is going to be ultimately
short-lived fame
uh we want to hopefully be done
with this question of is the former
president donald trump
going to be able to hide records phone
records and other records
from the lead up to
and the immediate aftermath of the
january's twenties uh january 6 2021
trump riots the supreme court is now
rejecting donald trump's bid
to hide the riot records is this finally
going to be the end
i really hope so first of all remember
the context this is about riot records
being provided to the january 6th house
committee
that is investigating the trump riots
abc news cbs news rather reports the
supreme court on tuesday turned away
former president donald trump's legal
fight with the white house with the
house select committee investigating the
january sixth assault on the u.s capitol
bringing an end we can only hope
bringing an end to the former
president's quest to stop investigators
from accessing reams of documents from
his final weeks in the white house trump
asked the supreme court in december
to take up his appeal of a decision from
the federal appeals court in washington
d.c
which rejected his efforts to shield the
documents from lawmakers and found trump
provided quote no basis for it to
override president biden's decision
not to uphold his predecessor's claim of
executive privilege over the records in
rejecting the former president's request
the decision from the u.s court of
appeals for the district of columbia
circuit remains in place
in addition to asking the supreme court
to review the lower court's decision
trump requested the justices to stop the
transfer of records from the national
archives to house investigators they
declined to do so last month and the
select committee received more than 700
pages of records sought by the panel
earlier this month so is this finally
the end i really hope so because i am so
sick of this he was president
those are our records these are not
trump's documents to control these are
our records and they should go to the
committee investigating this
and of course you are innocent until
proven guilty trump has not been charged
with anything he gets an opportunity for
all of that stuff
in a colloquial setting like this which
is not a court of law this is just a
show
one would naturally wonder
why would you be so anxious for those
records not to become public
if you have nothing to hide now there
are two explanations and i want to be
fair one explanation is he has something
to hide that's a completely reasonable
colloquial explanation we might all come
to without saying that means he is
legally guilty of anything he just he
has stuff to hide fine
the other one and it could be this
is that it's a really effective legal
strategy
you always push back and you always
obstruct everything even really simple
requests uncontroversial requests even
if later it'll be revealed there was no
criminal wrongdoing there or whatever
and that makes it harder to figure out
when is trump really being sketchy and
really has something to hide and what i
mean by that is imagine that there were
10 requests made of donald trump and
trump's really only concerned about one
of those requests and that's the only
one that he fights you're you're
telegraphing
where investigators should really be
paying attention you're signaling where
is the wrongdoing really hidden
if there are 10 requests made
and you're only worried about one of
them
but you try to obstruct all 10 you are
making it more difficult to determine
which of these ten things should we
really be focusing on and so i i think
that that it's completely plausible that
that's just the legal strategy here and
that's why donald trump is doing this in
terms of trump's willingness to
put records out there remember that he
was just about to publish those tax
returns back in 2015
and then 2016 as soon as the irs audit
was done
and we never got those tax
tax records so we know he never has any
intention of publishing anything last
thought
imagine being an adult
and seeing trump's behavior forget about
during his presidency but just over the
last year since he's been out of office
and still being impressed with him and
thinking that he's an alpha and thinking
that he's smart and a good business
person and a good decision maker it says
almost more about the people that still
support the guy than it does about trump
himself uh send me your thoughts you can
find us on facebook at facebook.com
davidpakmanshow
after this break we're gonna hear from
merrick garland and much more
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
okay so one of the questions for uh like
a year i guess but particularly in the
last three to four months is what is
happening at the justice department
under the stewardship of attorney
general merrick garland why is there not
uh investigation criminal investigation
going on of at least some of the things
that former president donald trump did
we have now received confirmation from
the attorney general merrick garland
that the justice department indeed
received
um information about the classified
records found among the documents
recovered from trump's mar-a-lago and
that the justice department is looking
into it now uh this colloquially means
that they are investigating whether this
would technically be called an open
criminal investigation is a question
mark um npr reporting attorney general
merrick garland said the justice
department is aware that classified
material has been found on trump's
mar-a-lago property but didn't
explicitly confirm a federal probe is
underway
let's take a look at the video clip this
is during a press conference the audio
is not great but i think we will be able
to make out what's being said question
last week the national archives revealed
that it found classified information in
15 boxes of documents stored at
mar-a-lago is the justice department
investigating to determine how the how
that classified information got during
who might have accessed it so as a
as the archivist said in a letter that
was sent to the congress uh the national
archives has informed the justice
department of this and communicated with
it
uh and we will do what we always do
under these circumstances uh look at the
facts and law and take it from there so
you know it he's using very careful
language he says we have received the
information
and we are going to
do what we always do we're going to look
at the facts and we're going to look at
the law now i think he's being very
careful here he is not saying we have
opened a federal investigation because
that's very specific and formal language
he is saying
we are investigating and at this point
is this merely a semantic question it
may be because i see no interest
whatsoever
in seriously
um uh
looking at the possibility of indicting
donald trump i mean i just i just don't
see it so
the fact that he's informally saying
there's an investigation without calling
it a federal probe i think is not
ultimately going to be super meaningful
now of course at this point there would
be a real question
for all the people who back in 2016 said
i'm not voting for hillary i'm voting
for trump because hillary can't be
trusted with sensitive information
hillary can't be trusted with classified
information or emails the private email
server etc etc
those people should now be saying wow
if those were my concerns with hillary i
never should have voted for donald trump
but if you actually go and talk to them
the vast majority will just excuse away
this behavior and say it's not really
that bad or trump was justified in doing
it or it's a witch hunt or the claims
are untrue or whatever the case may be
i've even seen uh online
some conservative uh
they're not really conservative some
trumpian reactionaries saying
trump did everything right here trump's
own people found the classified
documents and called the national
archives and said hey guys we've got
this stuff you should come and get it
really quickly there is no evidence that
that's what took place right the the the
narrative they want to create is
trump had no idea about these documents
and um trump staff found them and
immediately of their own volition called
the national archives and said come and
get the documents of course there is no
evidence that that is the story but at
the end of the day
i don't believe merrick garland has any
interest in indicting a former president
and the fact that they are generally
investigating without confirming an open
federal probe
uh is a distinction
but i don't think it will make a
functional difference in terms of what
we are to expect if you think garland
might have an appetite for indicting
trump
let me know i've seen no evidence to
suggest that that's the case
we are getting ready for cpac cpac is
the conservative political action
conference earlier in the show and
earlier in the week i told you about
some of the people that would be
speaking donald trump will be speaking
donald trump jr will be speaking
kimberly guilfoyle will be speaking uh
you know charlie kirk and uh different
members of congress tulsi gabbard will
be speaking sort of a shock to some
because she was a democrat and ran as a
democrat but of course she's extremely
reactionary and fits in much better with
the fox news crowd than with any
leftists i know she will be speaking at
cpac so the speakers are one side of it
my colleague john pointed out to me that
he was looking at the sponsors list for
cpac and a lot of them are the usual
suspects but there's some pretty weird
stuff so you know if you look at the
sponsors page you see that fox nation is
sponsoring that's fox news's streaming
platform you see that some of the big
sponsors are the japanese conservative
union that might sound weird but that
there's actually a big trump japan
movement
the republican national committee is
sponsoring and you know a whole bunch of
others you look at partnering sponsors
and the epic times which are a
right-wing media outlet getter which is
like a right wing twitter they're all
sponsoring you then look at supporting
sponsors and it's a lot of the common
ones heritage foundation and other think
tanks tea party patriots action on and
on
you look at contributing sponsors and
it's turning point usa and others you
then look at participating sponsors and
you still see
some names you recognize right side
broadcasting network and others and then
you go to exhibitors and there's a whole
list of stuff that we don't really
recognize and one of them in particular
caught my eye caught john's eye and he
told me about it and it's called enemies
within the church
this is just unbelievable and we could
pick any one of these and do this but
let's just look at this one enemies
within the church
is i guess that you would call it a
documentary film
and
what they seem to be arguing is
the church has now been infected with
left-wing propaganda
the film which we're going to look at
the trailer of here
feels that the institution of the church
is too liberal and it's basically going
communist just like they feel our
colleges have this this is incredible
who would fund this trash look at the
trailer let's listen what happened
to the church
to the living powerful transformative
nation-shaking christianity
what they're trying to do
is completely demolish western
civilization and then to rebuild it
in a just society
how do you break down american
christianity
i think the problem today in our culture
as many of our words have been co-opted
and stolen and dumbed down and reversed
social justice is sold as something that
it isn't
critical race this is dystopia porn over
the church being too liver liberal
understand that that's the core here
theory is sold as something that it
isn't
whiteness has caused blindness of heart
whiteness has caused blindness of heart
when you preach victimization
it always leads to vengeance advice us
against them me against you i want my
pound of flesh american churches today
are where the universities were 10 years
ago pretty heavily marxist they're not
quite there yet but they're well on the
way many of the seminaries and bible
colleges are definitely already there
that message that they're going out and
taking the world is not you need to
repent of your sin
receive christ
instead the message that you actually
have is they are under the weight of
racism or sexism or homophobia and then
we need to unify them together i'm gay
i'm 29 i'm a youth pastor in new jersey
uh oh nothing more dangerous than a gay
youth pastor guys these people are
really out there and this is the new
target the the church liberal churches
is the new enemy i'm straight and i'm
also a youth pastor of new jersey we're
planning on sharing life together for
the rest of our lives which we're not
totally sure what that looks like
obviously nick is straight and he does
plan on getting married
when he has a wife one day she'll make
those decisions with us
the future damage of what we're doing
now is just going to be enormous the
entire fabric of family personal wealth
private property all those things are
out the door now understand that
when you
stake out the position
that
college now college is liberal
indoctrination you send your kids to
college it's going to be a real problem
there can't do it
uh regular elementary school no no no no
kids are being taught about slavery
and uh you got a homeschool christian
homeschooling church well church is fine
right
that's the safe place for this idea
no
the churches are becoming marxist
uh social justice
um places and though you gotta keep your
kids out of that they are going in the
direction of the only place that's okay
is some small cult cult-like enclave
that is quite frankly reminiscent of of
jim jones right the the drink the
kool-aid people at the end of the day
that's what they are building here
you're only safe in your little cult
even the church is dangerous now and
everything is the state they believe the
state is god they don't define justice
the same way as the scripture oh no it's
going to be an equality all right
and it's going to be a totalitarian
marxist justice
so that's just we get and again we could
we could look at a ton of these that's
one spot exhibitor
at cpac the people who feel churches are
become and they use uh they they use
um all sorts of communist imagery there
as well if you were just listening the
church has become a communist
marxist
social justice
entryway
into dangerous leftism according to
these folks now the funny thing is
if this actually had the effect of
weakening the lobbying power of churches
it might actually be a good thing the
problem is what they're advocating is
get out of those churches come to the
right churches make sure they remain
fully funded etc we're going to be
covering cpac and it's going to be
insane the sponsors are insane the
exhibitors are radical it's all crazy
but as i said yesterday
we don't have this level of organization
on the left
we we just don't we and we need it and
part of why the country keeps going to
the left
but they keep winning elections is
because they have this level of
organization they have this level of
funding
um and it's it's not at some point it
will hurt the left
it is hurting the left it has hurt the
left for a very long time
we have a voicemail number and that
number is
2192 david p
here is a very fair question about
electric vehicles let's take a listen
hey david i just have a question about
electric cars i'm all for it the only
thing is that electricity still is
produced with coal and natural gas and
fossil fuels so
how
is it that
it's going to save anything because i
feel like what we're doing is removing
the fuel from the actual car just to a
power plant in someone's neighborhood
hopefully there's a better answer there
is so here's the deal first of all it is
not true
that all electricity comes from fossil
fuels but most electricity still does
come from fossil fuels although it is
diminishing in the united states i've
spoken to energy activists and
technologists about this exact issue you
plug in the electric car great the car
drives around and there's no emissions
but that electricity
came from fossil fuels first of all
you can power electric vehicles with
renewably sourced electricity
i have solar panels
and then i've got the electric car
so
it's coming from the sun now the solar
panels have
some of a carbon footprint that's true
they were manufactured and they were
shipped but it is lower but you can
power electric vehicles with renewables
you can generate electricity with solar
and wind you've also got non-renewable
but more efficient geothermal
new safe nuclear i'm not a new
pro-nuclear activist but i recognize
that if we built new nuclear now it
would not be like what there was 50
years ago okay fine we don't even need
to get into it most of the electricity
is not coming from renewables but you
can get uh electricity from renewables
so if you're driving around in a gas
powered car
you're burning fuel
and
as more electricity comes from
renewables you're still driving around
in a gas-powered car there's no way
to make the gas-powered car renewable if
you have the electric car as electricity
transitions away from fossil fuels
more and more vehicle miles are being
powered by renewable energy okay that's
number one
second
even if electricity is coming from say
uh you know i don't know
some kind of fossil fuel
if the fossil fuel is all being burned
in one place
rather than coming out of a million
vehicle tailpipes
you still have a better chance at
figuring out how to capture the
emissions from those fossil fuels
all at the power plant rather than
having to figure out what to do with a
million different tail pipes that are
driving around so you're kind of just
pushing up the energy ladder you're
obviously completely right that right
now most electricity still does come
from fossil fuels but it doesn't have to
um and more importantly that's going to
transition over time
that's the answer you know we we've
interviewed energy experts on this and
i've spoken to them personally and and
that's essentially the way it works uh
and uh the transition that we need to
keep pushing is for more and more
electricity
and this is by the way the same reason
that
if you have an electric oven
once the electricity comes from a
renewable you've closed the loop if you
have a gas oven
no matter what you're burning fossil
fuels and that's a lot of the reason why
one of the big moves right now in
renewable energy is let's start
retrofitting an entire go building by
building
you put solar panels on the roof you put
in an electric heat pump mini split type
system for heating you put in an
electric oven it's now and you put in a
car charger and then you you plug in
your car you've now gone from the roof
to the garage so to speak on electric
and it can come from renewable energy so
that's why there's so much focus on that
right now we have a great bonus show for
you today
new york as the pandemic waynes
wants to get people riding the subway
again
one of the reasons a lot of people
aren't going back to the new york
subways is because there are lots of
people living in the subways and there
are more incidents of sucker punches and
people being pushed in front of trains
that are being reported on i don't know
if it's happening more but it's being
reported on it more and new york city
wants to deal with that but how are they
going to deal with that is it going to
be oppressive we're going to talk about
that number two democrats have again
introduced a bill to eliminate these tax
subsidies when sports teams build new
stadiums
maybe will it pass this time we will
discuss
and we have a new study that
claims
that when there are stand your ground
laws enacted
homicides go up 11
not
justifiable uses of guns for
self-defense
legal homicide illegal homicides go up
11 we're gonna talk about that on the
bonus show
all of those stories and more are at
your fingertips when you sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the code wow
22 on our website to get a discount we
will speak to you then